in more detail with us is Natasha Bevan
founder of the self-esteem team a
campaign group that works with teenagers
on mental health and body image and
writer and broadcaster and mischief
maker nearly a year natheless let's
think how we get on today it's great to
see you Natasha congratulations on the
MBE by the way thank you for taking the
time to join us this afternoon you
presumably I'm sure you've welcomed the
decision what impact might it have I
think
body image the more I learn about it the
more complicated I realize it is and
things like mannequins and adverts
they're their symbols really I think
more than anything of the pressures that
women face so Topshop decision is a
victory but it's not going to change
it's not going to change anything
significant I don't think why not
because it runs so deep it's in the very
fabric of our society and that's why we
go into schools and work on changing
mindsets and giving young people the
armor they need to question capitalism
because it is it's in the very fabric of
the world that we live in a mannequin it
might shock you out of your revelry and
that's certainly what's happened with
this campaign but this stuff is all
around us all the time what's
extraordinary isn't it to hear about the
fact that this apparently problem with
women weren't worrying about being too
thin that's of course not the problem
the problem is everyone's getting too
fat and actually there's no evidence
really that any of this stuff has much
of an impact a lot of the science is
very fuzzy on this it's social science
stuff rather than any any real sort of
reports or anything I mean what what
worries me about all this kind of stuff
is the implication that somehow we're
gonna make people's lives happier or
better by encouraging them to believe
that whatever body shape they're on
whatever they look like they're
beautiful and they're going to be happy
that's evident there's quite clearly not
the case I mean if you look at women's
on twins happiness has been going down
since the Second World War actually
every decade that women are getting more
miserable as they get told that they can
be who they want and look how they like
and and you can say I suppose that a
woman's self-esteem should have nothing
to do with whether or not a man's sexual
preference you know sort of coincides
with how she looks but the fact is women
are getting more unhappy and this sort
of slightly irresponsible trend to sort
of encourage people to eat whatever they
want and do whatever they want is what
you know is one of the things that's
fueling an obese
that's a really serious thing that's a
real thing that something that's got
health implications it's got cost
implications for the NHS the problem
isn't too many anorexic women the
problem is quite in the opposite
direction we're perfectly happy to have
aspirational role models in our
entertainment we should have them too in
our retail there's nothing wrong with
encouraging people to live healthily
there's so much wrong with what you just
said first of all but the message is not
eat whatever you want sit on your sofa
and eat lard all day the message is live
a healthy lifestyle and then see how
your body ends up there's quite a wide
spectrum within which the human body can
exist and be healthy human beings come
in lots of different shapes and sizes
and that should be reflected in retail
because after all it's us that's
spending our money on those clothes
there's also evidence to show that our
thin worshipping culture is actually
what's fueling the obesity crisis that
it makes people feel shameful but it
makes people eat more it makes people
feel excluded from the world of health
I was recently in Copenhagen a place
where they are obsessed with health in a
very positive way and the manikins I
noticed were a little larger so why not
allow people that the freedom to see
themselves reflected in shop windows I
don't think that anybody's complaining
about you know having realistic types if
if they want them in certain places the
problem is when you start sort of
bullying retailers into getting rid of
aspirational body types making clothes
look worse in the window I mean when a
woman goes shopping for example she
quite often looks at clothes that are a
smaller size than she'll actually works
they want to she wants to know how that
garments actually going to look these
sorts of aspirational love how we're
being told what women look for well
obviously you're from the sort of
mansplaining school of feminism which of
course also hates capitalism as we heard
earlier and there's always you know what
I really don't like about this debate is
it's a sort of women on women kind of
violence this isn't really about whether
it's a hetero patriarchal capitalistic
sort of superstructure or weird
atmosphere that is encouraging women to
have unhealthy attitudes towards their
bodies this is really about
unfortunately very often is older women
who aren't very happy taking out their
frustration on younger women and on
youth culture and if you look
unfortunately a lot of the activists who
do this the people who make the
complaints the journalists the media
figures who are doing this very often
they are older very often they are
single very often they are
taking out you know their frustrations
and their own personal lives on brands
that are aimed at 22 year old girls who
are much closer to the sorts of body
shapes that we see in the windows you're
taking out your frustration on the youth
of today well I've been completely
misrepresented which of course is when
you're losing an argument is the easiest
thing to do is its try and put me in a
box where I'm suddenly a militant
feminist I am a former model I've worked
in the fashion industry I know that it's
run mainly by women and homosexual men
and so the patriarchy really doesn't
have that much of an impact in that
sphere and also you know it's when I
want go shopping what I want to know is
what the garment will look like on me
not on a six-foot one dummy with the 26
inch waist
if you cannot design for a realistic
body shape then you're not a very good
designer if you can only design for a
coat hanger you're creating art not a
garment that's designed for a human body
I'm not sure where this sort of
obsession with realism and realistic
proportions has come from I mean you
could there are blogs sort of feminist
blogs out there that show you know
videogame characters in more realistic
proportions they turn lara croft into
this sort of dumpy lesbionic you know
short woman in cargo pants and everyone
really wants to see that nobody wants
not even women there's not an aspiration
I like our sort of icon that people can
aspire to be like the fact is we do have
a huge problem with people tweeting
their own health very irresponsibly and
I personally find when when media
figures and feminists and and activists
and campaigners encourage women to
worship themselves no matter what their
size and what their shape actually that
just has the effect of making women
unhappy and women have been getting more
unhappy decade after decade after decade
since the Second World War since this
stuff started to happen okay we've been
what do you basing we're not being
offensive
mm-hm are we no so what would you cement
science okay I would like to see
diversity on the high street because I
don't want to see naturally slender
women excluded from the world of fashion
either you take any one beauty paradigm
you take a size 16 mannequin you take a
size 0 mannequin and present that as the
only way to be beautiful both of those
are problematic I want to see lots of
different shapes sizes ages and races on
the high street and I think I disagree I
think that will lead to greater
happiness for women it's not really true
is it I mean people don't want to see
diversity they always seem to want to
see larger models of large and
Anakin's I mean the the directions of
trajectory of pressure from see what
clothes will look like before they try
them on like on them by trying them on
yeah I mean designers put clothes on
skinny women because it looks better
because that's what people I mean the
fact is you know again this is not
really about men at all this is about
pressures that women put on other women
you know to look good and to stay thin
and to stay healthy and frankly those
women who do aspire to look like what
you know you may think a sort of
stereotypical standards of beauty or
unattainable sort of Beauty sense women
who do look like that tend to be happier
they tend to get better success in
relationships and they tend to report
that they're more content with life when
I said the in women are getting more
unhappy or every decade I'm just pulling
that out of my behind women these days
report as as compared to even fifty
years ago they're far more depressed
they're far more likely to report
themselves as generally unhappy with
life they're far more like to be single
and they're far more likely to
contemplate suicide and a lot of this
has got to do with the fact that after
30 women do struggle to be happy if
they're not in relationships and part of
the reason that many women are in
relationships is you've got these weird
celebrities like Lena Dunham who put
sort of you know being quivering and
blobby and unpleasant as a sort of
virtue on our screens encouraging women
to turn themselves into quite
unattractive you know sort of spectacles
I don't think that's particularly
healthy for anybody but ultimately it
doesn't really affect men I said it
doesn't affect me as a homosexual it
just affects women because you're making
women unhappy the final thought is that
what we should find aspirational is
health you can't look at somebody and
ascertain how healthy they are health is
about lifestyle not looks so I want to
encourage people to celebrate their
bodies because people who like their
bodies look after them so same as with a
car if you had a lovely shiny new car
you would clean it regularly you'd put
the right fuel into it their bodies look
for affirmations self-help you know sort
of motivational speaking of the kind
that you know that you do because they
want to feel good about how they look no
matter what their size or shape even if
we're not about their bodies go to the
gym well I go to the gym and I'm not
single I've been I'm in a long-term
relationship I think that you use
stereotype to women who want to see
diversity because it makes you feel
better
and militant I want to see diversity I
want to celebrate women I love women I
love fashion and I want to see everybody
invited to the fashion party and I don't
think that there's anything wrong with
that
do you love women of course great good
to see bow